[Music]
Diane is in Harrisburg Pennsylvania hi
Diane how are you hi Dave thanks for
taking my call I'm grateful for you well
I'm honored thanks how can I help
well I'm a 54 year old woman single
woman I have about $40,000 that I moved
from a band guard account to a
investment professional and I'm playing
a little bit of catch-up obviously he
did a profile on me and said that I was
a moderately aggressive investor and I
know that you're aggressive investor
days so I'm wondering with the split
that he gave me saying he wanted to cut
13% in bonds which could be ETF he said
they could be mutual funds 2% cash and
85% stock fund I'm wondering what you
say about that since he says I'm
moderately aggressive and that I don't
fall under aggressive investor my luck I
don't believe any of that crap okay so I
I basically tell everyone and I do the
same thing by the way to invest their
money in four types of mutual funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international and that will
about and buy mutual funds that are
outperforming the S&P 500 and ride them
out and that's how people build wealth
you know this idea that we're gonna play
footsie with your feelings is not is not
a plan I don't care what your feelings
are I want you to grow your
understanding of how investments work
and understand that when you buy the
group of mutual funds I just talked
about he would classify that as
aggressive I don't give a crap how you
aggress how he does it that group of
mutual funds is more stable than the
home you own so I don't know how in a
flip you call that aggressive but some
of these characters and their little
formulas and crap that they do in the
financial world have dreamed up all this
to try to do a risk analysis a risk
assessment and you know what what is
your risk tolerance and all this kind of
stuff and basically you know what your
risk tolerance changes as you know as
you understand what's going on and your
knowledge base can increase your risk
tolerance you know when you first start
driving a car your risk tolerance for
driving a car you're nervous and scared
you don't know how to drive a car you
don't any risk tolerance right now with
this but that doesn't mean you don't
drive a car you still start driving the
car and you know what the more you drive
the car unless you're the less you're
stressed out about it and risk tolerance
goes up you tolerate the risk of
automobiles being around you you
tolerate the risk of driving at a higher
speed than thirty miles an hour and you
know that kind of thing and that you
know but no we're gonna buy you a car
that doesn't go over thirty because
you're stressed is a new driver horse
crap so I'm not doing that now go to
Dave Ramsey calm click on smart Wester
and give them one of our smart Wester
pros that we endorse and they'll help
you get out of this mess this is the
Dave Ramsey show
[Music]